after a long investigation two former
members of the now disbanded resurgence
of valor and roster
have been banned from the valor and
champions tour for
three years for match fixing their
teammates have received
similar punishments for not telling riot
that they knew
what was going on there were thousands
of dollars involved
there are some leaked text messages it's
pretty ugly stuff
and it's the first major match fixing
scandal
in valorance history
[Music]
all right guys before we get into this i
have to tell you for every sub we get on
this channel
one match fixer gets banned okay
that might not be exactly true but
you'll never know unless you're
subscribed
ah see what i did there make sure you're
subscribed well there's a first time for
everything
valorant has joined what feels like
every other major esport out there
by having its first ever match-fixing
scandal
and it ain't pretty on wednesday riot
published the results of their
investigation
into a game between resurgence and
blackbird ignis from september 2020.
quote valor and esports has ruled that
malcolm
germs g chung and ryan dreamy cs go
tan have violated rule 7.2.1
and 7.2.4 of the valerant global
competition policy
for manipulating the outcome of a
competitive valorem match for monetary
gain
they will be banned from ballarat
champions tour for
36 months the game was part of the e
polls
royal sea cup a southeast asian
tournament with a winning prize of 25
000
us dollars the investigation focused on
two members in particular
germs and dreamy cs go former members
of the now disbanded resurgence now riot
said they launched the investigation
immediately after becoming aware of
allegations of
match fixing now while we don't know
exactly when that was
it could be as far back as april 2021
that's when a valorem player from
singapore known as kl
tweeted out a google doc called exposing
a parasite in the valoran
sgmy community it was an expose of one
of the players eventually named in
riot's investigation germs
this dock includes screenshots of a
what's up conversation allegedly
involving germs
according to k-l the conversation shows
a person called germs discussing how
they bet
2 000 singapore dollars on their own
team losing a valorem match
a link is shared which allegedly leads
to a betting slip showing numerous bets
on resurgence
losing to blackbird ignis over three
thousand dollars had been staked
now we can't say for sure if this person
was germs but
whoever it was they were about to win
big
that round
but look at that bbi bbi closing it out
saying
we don't want any more we have had
enough and that is going to be
the game in game one resurgence lost
13-10 to blackbird ignis with germs kda
at 9
18 2. in game two resurgence got clapped
even harder
players they're gonna double peaky maybe
oh joking gets a kill oh it and
it it's all over here but now i'm not
able to do anything as bvi
will secure their spot might secure the
spot sorry
in the main event in game two resurgence
got stomped
513 by bbi and germs fared
even worse this time with his kda at 7
16 and 3. now if germs was the one who
bet
3 000 on his team losing 2-0
he would have won a lot of money with an
average odds multiplier of 2.34 across
the bets
the profits on those bets would have
been around four
thousand dollars the google doc also
contains more screenshots of this
alleged whatsapp conversation
talking about bad kda not even trying
and using different mouse sensitivity
there's also a forwarded message from
what is alleged to be the manager
of resurgence at the time telling the
team good try
and this is supposedly proof that the
team's management didn't suspect a thing
the dock then finishes off with k-l
pointing out that germs went on to play
for team 600 having never been caught or
punished for the alleged match fixing so
as i said before
we don't know exactly when riot started
looking into all of this but given the
evidence put forward by kl
it's possible that this was when they
started looking into it
it's important to note that riot's
report doesn't reference these whatsapp
conversations as
evidence but it does include some other
shocking details
quote bryant's investigation found that
malcolm germs ji
chung and ryan dreamy cs go tan
coordinated to bet against their own
team resurgence
germs g initiated the scheme and dreamy
cs go provided the capital
germsg then informed the rest of the
resurgence roster
about his bet riot found that the rest
of resurgence's roster
did not want to throw the match but
purposefully concealed the issue from
their management
and valor and esports officials because
they were concerned about penalties and
risking their contracts with resurgence
this is pretty shocking because it means
that according to riot
the other players on the team knew that
their teammates were trying to throw the
game
intentionally and they didn't say
anything and from there
riot's report gets even more wild quote
following the match which resulted in a
2-0 win for blackbird ignis
germs attempted to pay off other
individuals in the resurgence roster
however this was rejected by the
resurgence players
the roster was disbanded the following
month end quote so according to riot
not only did germs tell his teammates he
was going to bet on them losing and
essentially throw the game he tried to
bribe them to be in on the scheme
too to be clear riot says that while
these other teammates rejected the offer
and played to win they were implicated
in the investigation
because riot says they didn't tell them
or their management
about what germs was up to before we
unpack all of that we need to talk about
the actual
ruling riot says that the punishments
would be different for each of the
players
depending on their level of culpability
and right off the bat
that does make sense i mean the entire
team was implicated in this as soon as
they decided
to not tell riot about the match fixing
scheme but obviously you can't punish a
player for not coming forward about one
of their teammates breaking the rules
as severely as the player that match
fixed in the first place
and with that in mind riot decided to
dish out the penalties
as follows germs was banned for three
years the same punishment was given to
dreamy csgo
who helped fund germs betting according
to riot
this means that those players won't be
able to return to the scene
until april 2024
that is basically a life sentence in
esports terms
bob leck and jab the boy received
valorant champions tour bands for one
year
while mordecai and benath received six
months
each now you might be wondering why
those other teammates receive
different punishments despite none of
them actually being the ones who match
fixed
according to riot they're also basing
the level of punishment depending on the
level of cooperation
from the players during the
investigation so
apparently some players cooperated a lot
more than others so
are the punishments fair well there's a
lot of different ways to look at this
on the one hand these young players may
have been scared about the penalties
that would be issued
if this scandal got out in the report
riot themselves say that apparently the
players didn't come
forward because they were scared of
losing their contracts
and like yeah of course you'd be these
kids probably worked their asses off to
play valorum at the pro level and didn't
want this scandal just [ __ ] it up for
them
but at the end of the day if a player
wants to play in the valorum's champions
tour
they have to agree to riot's rules quote
if a team member is
asked to fix the outcome of a game or to
otherwise take part in
any actions prohibited by this global
policy
or the applicable event specific rules
that team member
must immediately report this request to
the tournament operator
so yeah they didn't match fix themselves
but they agreed to these rules which
says
that they have to tell riot if they
witness any attempt to match fix
and they didn't and presumably because
money was also involved in all of this
they also included the other rule that
was broken rules 7.25
gambling players are not allowed to
gamble on the outcome of any tournament
because as riot puts it
it poses a serious threat to the
competitive integrity of its game
and yeah i don't need to tell you guys
that if players were allowed to make
money
betting on tournaments even if it wasn't
one of their own games
it would be a [ __ ] fest i wouldn't trust
anything that i saw
and that's what this is all about trust
sure
this is just a few players on one team
in one part of the world but
it's more than just that valorum is
coming into its own
as an esport it's got millions of fans
it's just had a really successful first
international lan event
people are hyped but they need to trust
in its competitive integrity going
forward
they need to know that the games that
they're watching are free
of any match fixing or inside gambling
riot has stamped out what looks to be
the first
major example of that and let's hope
they continue to do so
as valeran grows so yeah they didn't
match fix themselves but they agreed to
these rules which says that
they they didn't
guys